dr. mycelium what's your personal
opinion about this combination therapy
I think this combination therapy is a
very good way to treat it we know
nowadays that there are different ways
and of course a lot of different ways to
treat tinnitus but this is a very good
method yeah so it is very difficult to
treat tinnitus especially when it
becomes chronic why is it that it's very
difficult for chronic diseases to be
treated you have to imagine that the
chronic disease always give give us some
problems concerning treatment because
it's so long-lasting so to go into this
process and to break it down to find new
ways for the patient is a hard way I
really remember patient of mine in my
surgery and this was a female and she
was suffering from tinnitus for about I
think four or five years and after those
five years the team just wasn't just
there and and she came into my office
said my tinnitus is gone and she was
very afraid and said I'm missing the
tinnitus I'm very used to it now it's
all silence here is it a typical patient
yeah it's not really a typical patient
if you have this case so that somebody's
coming into your practice and talking
about I would like to have my tinnitus
back
this is absolutely rare the normal
patient has these kind of symptoms and
it's going down like just like a like a
fever curve going up and down the
complaint so this is more typical bout
that the treatment is not all about
coping mechanism so if patients cope
isn't in it is better and it's a better
chance of healing like if I say I'm
better used to it and they don't but it
doesn't bother me at all the tinnitus so
some patients are bothered and others
say and I don't care at all the best way
is just to just ignore it is the best
way of treatment this is better and then
what's your personal approach when it
comes to chronic tinnitus so my personal
approach is just to try to talk with the
patient counseling and to investigate
different things - to talk to the
patient that there's nothing severe
behind these symptoms okay okay and
there are some modern devices you can
put inside the ear they're making noises
like a hearing aid and do you use them
so a hearing aid is
if you have a hearing loss so then it's
of course a good way to treat it and
there's another way I think what you
mean our tinnitus maskers these are able
to just yeah to cover the sound to do
yeah get it behind in life so don't
think about that but this is only
working during day when the patients are
wearing these devices okay and then
should they wear it overnight as well
it's possible but most of the people
doesn't do that because they sleep yeah
so what do you person think about
alternative complementary treatments
like acupuncture treatment I think there
are of course some different ways but
that what we are talking usually about
that some something like magnetic
therapies or soft laser methods this is
really not evidence-based okay so um one
thing could be just to make some sounds
inside the ear like in this device and
our viewer Breanna la cámara phone who I
wanted to know should you rest your ears
go to his silent plays in nature for
instance to get rid of attention this is
usually not the best way to treat it if
it's if it's just quiet outside if
you're looking for such a situation then
the complaints are coming more up so
just behave like always and try to be in
your life as always okay so as an ENT
doctor are there any special or secret
tips you would advise me you know I
think a very good way would be a
relaxation therapy if you try this or if
you have a problem with the hearing just
avoid noises loud noises okay and you
can even do this before it comes to
tinnitus dr. Mason
thank you so much for being with us in
the studio thank you